is Warner Brothers really about to get
sold welcome to CI TV muga
channel so I've literally just had a
comment on the channel saying um that
somebody else's sources are telling them
that Warner Brothers is on the verge of
being sold and asking basically how true
that is at the moment Warner Brothers as
a company Warner Brothers Discovery has
somewhere in the region of 50 billion
dollars worth of debt now that is a
massive increase from the early 2020s I
think it was like 2021 they owed like
about 15 billion or something and it's
just massively increased over the last
couple of
years so now it is in the region of 50
billion they have been driving that debt
down but not quickly enough I have
actually been able to speak to a couple
of sources about this and I if you are a
regular Sid tracker you'll know just
about a month ago I did speak to you
guys about the possibility of Netflix
actually buying HBO's Max streaming
service and that that would become part
of Netflix bigger project so basically
you would get Netflix Regular and then
you get Netflix Max that would be then
added and for a small premium on top of
their normal sort of charge Apparently
that is a possibility because no one
company could buy Warner Brothers
particularly in its current form there's
just too much debt and the company is to
be honest vast you've got the studio
space which is one of the largest in
Southern California and just from a real
estate Point alone is worth significant
money they have a vast IP they have the
parks you know like Warner Brothers
Parks like Harry Potter land and all
these sorts of things and they have
things like Max so it is very likely
that in the next 12 to 18 months we are
going to see parts of that business sold
off as I said there is the POS
possibility that Netflix could purchase
Max and absorb it into the larger
service and that then a lot of Warner
Brothers products would be produced
directly for
Netflix there is a possibility that the
parks could be sold there is a
possibility that other assets which are
significant could be sold to other
providers
and there is a possibility that the
studio or at least parts of the studio
space at Warner Brothers Studios could
also be sold also though Warner Brothers
are having a massive push towards
limiting their liability and by this I
mean and they've already started doing
this selling programs to other shows so
that they're not actually
risking buying anything so you know they
they buy a show they produce a show it
bombs if you've got someone else to pay
for that already you you don't have any
liability so they have been moving
towards using their Studio space to
produce material for others this has
been why they were in conversations
about Stargate with Amazon even though I
think Amazon has moved on from that now
and why they're in conversations with
lots of other things like selling
existing TV shows from Max directly to
Netflix something they've never done
before so is Warner Brothers about to
get sold no
but is Warner Brothers moving slowly
towards being carved up and
sold yes there is also a possibility
that individual IP will be sold I.E for
example the movie rights for um Harry
Potter could be solve also and a big one
here is probably DC that there is a
distinct possibility they've created DC
Studios and the reason why they did that
at least in part is to make it a more
attractive and more sellable product
in the long run if it getss to that so
as we speak right now no one company
could come in and just buy Warner
Brothers but it is very likely that the
company will be carved up over the next
couple of years no business really of
that size and turnover could manage a
debt of $50 billion debt that has
increased massively over the last two
years and remembering that servicing
that debt this is a similar problem to
what Paramount has at the moment
servicing the debt is becoming more
expensive and Paramount only owes $15
billion Warner Brothers is
50 so thanks to the credit C and thanks
to interest rates going up we actually
could be at risk of losing two of the
biggest and oldest Studios in Hollywood
Paramount and Warner Brothers as
servicing their debt becomes more
expensive but guys get into the comments
tell me what you think is Warner
Brothers really up for sale and if so
who would take over one of the big
rumors is that Universal is the studio
that will come in and actually take on
the studio space and buy much of the
more valuable IP or is this actually
something that Apple might be involved
in possible they're probably the most
cashr Studio out there and they're the
only ones that probably could service
that sort of level of debt and also they
would be gagging for the studio space
and the IP that Warner Brothers has so
maybe get into the comments going and
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the channel don't forget to
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
yes I'm wearing a Christmas jumper it
was our Christmas jumper day today don't
have a go at me stay out the
comments as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next
[Music]
time